for the past four years they've barely
seen the inside of their schools first
it was coveted but now it's a political
and economic crisis keeping schools shut
most of the time
history teacher badara manikam traveled
120 kilometers to colombo last week to
protest against the country's leaders he
was injured when police tried to
disperse protesters with tear gas and
water cannons
i want students to be educated as a good
citizen father and teacher i want our
school system to be improved that's why
i took to the street
he uses a classroom inside his house to
prepare students for their exams despite
school closures but it's hard to study
if there's not enough to eat since an
economic crisis prices of food have gone
through the roof and millions of sri
lankans can only afford to consume one
or two meals a day eight organizations
say many children may severely be
malnourished
only one of giovanni pradipa's three
daughters is receiving an education the
single mother owns one mobile phone her
eldest uses it for online classes her
two youngest were forced to drop out of
school giovanni earns money by making
containers for paint
because of the economic crisis it's very
difficult for us we only eat twice a day
i can't feed my daughter's breakfast
because i don't have enough money to buy
food i also can't afford to stock up on
food and have to see what i can buy on a
daily basis it's very difficult living
with three children now
her eldest daughter's dream to become an
accountant
eight organizations fear one-fourth of
all sri lankans are at the brink of
malnutrition
that's a worry and that we are assuming
it's about six million people already in
that that crisis level and what will
happen 6 million is almost
1 4 of the population
so that is a huge worry for us what will
happen to
sri lanka and this large population in
next three to six months
a concern shared by bidari manikam who
is ready to go back to colombo to
protest if a new president and his
government do not improve the situation
quickly step faster al jazeera in candy